Creían que mi orientación sexual era culpa de EE.UU.
Occidente me había corrompido con ideas divergentes
y si tan solo mis padres nunca hubieran dejado Taiwán,
esto no le habría pasado a su única hija.
La verdad, me pregunté si tendrían razón.
Por supuesto, hay personas homosexuales en Asia,
al igual que hay la misma cantidad de gays en cada parte del mundo.
Pero ¿la idea de vivir una vida "distinta",
de "soy gay, esta es mi esposa y estamos orgullosas de nuestras vidas"
es solo una idea occidental?
Si hubiera crecido en Taiwán o en cualquier lugar distinto a Occidente,
¿hubiera encontrado modelos de personas LGBT felices y prósperas?
Dazols Lisa: Yo tenía ideas similares.
Como trabajadora social del VIH en San Francisco,
conocí a muchos inmigrantes gays.
Me contaban de la persecución en sus países de origen,
solo por ser gays
y las razones por las que escaparon a los EE.UU.
Vi cómo los habían golpeado.
Después de 10 años de hacer este tipo de trabajo,
necesitaba mejores historias para mí.
Sabía que el mundo no era perfecto,
pero seguramente no toda historia gay era trágica.
JC: Como pareja tuvimos la necesidad de encontrar historias de esperanza.
Así que viajamos por el mundo
buscando gente a la que hemos denominado "supergays".
Estos serían los individuos LGBT
que estaban haciendo algo extraordinario en el mundo.
Serían valientes, persistentes,
y sobre todo, orgullosos de quiénes eran.
Serían el tipo de persona a la que aspiro ser.
Nuestro plan era compartir sus historias con el mundo a través del cine.
LD: Pero había un problema.
No teníamos experiencia cinematográfica ni de reportaje.
Ni siquiera sabíamos dónde encontrar los supergays,
así que confiamos en que íbamos a resolverlo todo sobre la marcha.
Elegimos 15 países en Asia, África y América del Sur,
países fuera de occidente diferentes sobre los derechos LGBT.
Compramos una videocámara,
pedimos un libro sobre cómo hacer un documental...
(Risas)
se puede aprender mucho en estos días,
y salimos en un viaje alrededor del mundo.
JC: Uno de los primeros países fue Nepal.
A pesar de la pobreza generalizada, una guerra civil de una década,
y recientemente, un terremoto devastador,
Nepal ha dado pasos significativos en la lucha por la igualdad.
Una de las figuras clave en el movimiento es Bhumika Shrestha.
Una hermosa, vibrante mujer transexual,
Bhumika ha tenido que superar que la expulsaran de la escuela
y la encarcelaran por su apariencia de género.
Pero, en 2007, la organización de derechos LGBT de Bhumika Nepal
apeló con éxito a la Corte Suprema de Nepal
por protección contra la discriminación LGBT.
Esta es Bhumika:
(Video) BS: ¿De qué estoy más orgullosa?
Soy una persona transexual.
Estoy muy orgullosa de mi vida.
El 21 de diciembre 2007
el tribunal supremo dio la órden al gobierno de Nepal
de dar tarjetas de identidad transgénero
y el matrimonio entre personas del mismo sexo.
LD: Puedo apreciar la confianza de Bhumika diariamente.
Algo tan simple como usar un baño público
puede ser un gran desafío cuando no encajas
en las estrictas expectativas de género de las personas.
Al viajar a lo largo de Asia,
desconcertaba a las mujeres en los baños públicos.
No estaban acostumbradas a ver algo como yo.
Tuve que inventar alguna estrategia para que pudiera orinar en paz.
Así que cuando quería entrar a un baño
sacaba el pecho para mostrar mis partes femeninas,
y trataba de ser lo menos amenazante posible.
Sacaba mis manos y decía: "Hola"
solo para que la gente pudiera escuchar mi voz femenina.
Todo esto era agotador, pero es solo lo que soy.
No puedo ser otra cosa.
JC: Después de Nepal, viajamos a la India.
Por un lado, la India es una sociedad hindú,
sin una tradición de homofobia.
Pero por otra parte, es una sociedad profundamente patriarcal,
que rechaza cualquier cosa que amenace el orden masculino-femenino.
Cuando hablamos con activistas,
dijeron que el empoderamiento comienza con asegurar la igualdad de género,
donde se establezca el estatus de las mujeres en la sociedad.
De esta manera, la situación de las personas LGBT se puede afirmar también.
LD: Allí conocimos al príncipe Manvendra.
Es el primer príncipe abiertamente gay del mundo.
El príncipe Manvendra salió en el programa de Oprah Winfrey
muy internacional.
Sus familiares lo repudiaron
lo acusaron de traer una gran vergüenza para la familia real.
Nos sentamos con el príncipe Manvendra
hablamos con él acerca de por qué decidió a salir tan públicamente.
Aquí está:
(Video) Príncipe Manvendra: Sentía que había mucha necesidad
de romper el estigma y la discriminación existentes en nuestra sociedad.
Y eso me llevo a salir y a hablar de mí abiertamente.
Ya sea que seamos gays, lesbianas, transexuales, bisexuales
o cualquier minoría sexual,
tenemos que unirnos y luchar por nuestros derechos.
Los derechos de los homosexuales no pueden ganarse en los tribunales
sino en los corazones y las mentes de las personas.
JC: Al cortarme mi pelo,
la mujer que me lo cortaba me preguntó
"¿Tienes marido?"
Ahora, ese era un tema temido
que me preguntaban mucho los lugareños durante el viaje.
Cuando le expliqué que estaba con una mujer en lugar de un hombre,
no podía creerlo,
y me preguntó muchas cosas acerca de las reacciones de mis parientes
y si estaba triste porque nunca podría tener hijos.
Le dije que no existen limitaciones en mi vida
y Lisa y yo tenemos pensado hacer una familia algún día.
Esta mujer ya me daba por perdida
como otra occidental loca más.
No podía imaginar que tal fenómeno
pudiera suceder en su propio país.
Es decir, hasta que le mostré las fotos de los supergays
que entrevistamos en la India.
Reconoció al príncipe Manvendra de la televisión
y pronto tuve varias peluqueras
interesadas en conocerme.
(Risas)
Y en esa tarde ordinaria,
tuve la oportunidad de mostrar a un salón de belleza completo
el cambio social que estaba ocurriendo en su propio país.
LD: De la India viajamos a África Oriental,
una región conocida por la intolerancia hacia las personas LGBT.
En Kenia, el 89% de las personas gay
son repudiadas por su familia.
Los actos homosexuales son un delito y pueden llevar a la cárcel.
En Kenia, nos encontramos con la voz suave de David Kuria.
David tenía la enorme tarea de querer trabajar por los pobres
y mejorar su propio gobierno.
Así que decidió postularse para el senado.
Se convirtió en el primer candidato político abiertamente gay de Kenia.
David quería hacer su campaña sin negar la realidad de quién era.
Pero estaba preocupado por su seguridad
porque comenzó a recibir amenazas de muerte.
(Video) David Kuria: En ese momento estaba muy asustado
ya que en realidad pedían que me mataran.
Y, sí,
hay personas por ahí que lo harían
y creen que están cumpliendo un precepto religioso.
JC: David no estaba avergonzado de quién era.
Incluso aún con las amenazas,
permaneció auténtico.
LD: En el extremo opuesto del espectro está Argentina.
Argentina es un país con un 92% de la población identificada como católica.
Sin embargo, Argentina tiene leyes LGBT que son más progresista incluso
que las de aquí en los EE.UU.
En 2010, Argentina fue el primer país en América Latina
y el décimo en el mundo en adoptar el matrimonio homosexual.
Allí, nos encontramos con María Rachid.
María fue una fuerza impulsora detrás de ese movimiento.
JC: Cuando visitamos mis tierras ancestrales,
Me hubiera gustado poder mostrar a mis familiares lo que encontramos allí.
Porque esto es lo que encontramos:
(Video) Uno, dos, tres. ¡Bienvenido gays a Shanghai!
(Risas)
Toda una comunidad de jóvenes y hermosas personas LGBT chinas.
Claro, tenían sus luchas,
pero las estaban luchando.
En Shanghai, tuve la oportunidad de hablar con un grupo de lesbianas locales
y contarles nuestra historia en mi pobre chino mandarín.
En Taipei, cada vez que íbamos en el metro,
veíamos otras parejas de lesbianas agarradas de la mano.
Y nos enteramos de que el evento de orgullo LGBT más grande de Asia
ocurre a solo unas manzanas de donde mis abuelos viven.
Si mis padres lo supieran.
LD: Cuando terminamos nuestro viaje gay por el mundo,
(Risas)
Habíamos recorrido 80.000 km.
y registrado 120 horas de vídeo.
Viajamos a 15 países,
y entrevistamos a 50 supergays.
Resulta que no era difícil encontrarlos.
JC: Sí, todavía suceden tragedias
en el camino lleno de obstáculos a la igualdad.
No olvidemos que 75 países criminalizan la homosexualidad en la actualidad.
Pero también hay historias de esperanza y valor,
en todos los rincones del mundo.
Lo que a fin de cuentas aprendimos de nuestro viaje fue que
la equidad no es un invento occidental.
LD: Uno de los factores clave en este movimiento es el impulso,
impulso a medida que más y más gente acepta su ser completamente
y utilizan cualquier oportunidad que tengan
para cambiar su parte del mundo
y el impulso a medida que más y más países
encuentran modelos de equidad en otros países.
Cuando Nepal dio protección contra la discriminación LGBT
India empujó con más fuerza.
Cuando Argentina legalizó la equidad de la boda,
Uruguay y Brasil la siguieron.
Cuando Irlanda dijo que sí a la equidad,
(Aplausos)
el mundo se detuvo para darse cuenta de ello.
Cuando la corte suprema de EE. UU. hace una declaración al mundo
de la que todos podemos estar orgullosos.
(Aplausos)
JC: Al revisar nuestro material de archivo,
nos dimos cuenta de lo que estábamos viendo era una historia de amor.
Yo no esperaba una historia de amor,
sino una llena de más libertad, aventura y amor
de la que pude haber imaginado.
Un año después al volver a casa de nuestro viaje,
las bodas gays llegaron a California.
Y al final, creemos, el amor triunfará.
(Video) Por el poder que me confiere
el estado de California
y por Dios todopoderoso,
los declaro cónyuges para la vida.
Pueden besarse.
(Aplausos)